what's up guys
bang bang it is lunch money time it's
friday you know what that means pull
that trillionaire energy out i don't
care if you're drinking starbucks if
you're going to drink bud light tonight
or if you're going to sit inside with
your mask on and prevent everything from
happening
welcome to lunch money well while she's
trying to get rich restaurants just
trying to get our lunch money right
do not forget that lunch money no
coughing is
sponsored by block five block fly has
three products you can buy and sell
crypto on a crypto exchange you can
deposit crypto and earn up to eight
point six percent
apy in an interest bearing account you
ain't getting a legacy system or you can
deposit crypto take out a us dollar loan
to get your crypto collateral
go get a blockfi account blockfy.com
pomp blockhide.com you should be there
i'm an investor i'm a happy user and so
will you
if you go get an account what's up
so bluford putnam chief economist and
managing director of cme group
believes blueford
believes bitcoin is an emerging
competitor to gold
in a cme presented explainer video
posted by bloomberg putnam said the
yellow metals ongoing production
likely to increase in 2021 contrast with
bitcoin's
fixed supply bitcoin is a
10x maybe 100x improvement on gold from
a technology standpoint
bitcoin is superior to gold and guess
what the young people know
and the older people generally don't
know there are some older people who get
it there are some younger people who are
confused
but what i'm going to say is bitcoin is
superior the market is determining that
and i personally believe that bitcoin's
market cap will
surpass gold's market cap by the end of
this decade
before 2030 i think that bitcoin's
market cap which currently sits around
six seven hundred billion dollars
will surpass gold's market capital 10
trillion dollars
so buckle up put your seatbelt on put
your helmet on
get your arms and your legs inside the
vehicle and get ready for takeoff have
you guys seen that meme
where it's a little bitcoin on a roller
coaster and it's just like
yeah have you also seen the meme where
they're on the roller coaster they're
only going up
no there is no such thing no there is
i'll show you later everything that goes
up must come down
that's not true the stock market only
goes up
facts and calm down no it doesn't it's
laws of physics
72 million value oh my god
tomorrow and nevermind 72 million
dollar crypto fund backed by paul tudor
jones and ll cool j comes
out of stealth never thought i'd read
that
paul tudor jones and ll cool j were
behind the same thing well this is
what's called north high
north island ventures north island
ventures is uh a fund
72 million bucks uh glenn hutchins uh
is behind he he's the one well glenn
hutchins son
is one of the two people i think josh
harris is also behind it yeah
josh harris apollo group uh
news newey i think so you pronounce her
name uh the former pepsi ceo there's a
bunch of big names behind the [ __ ] what
is this
uh well they're all interested in
learning but isn't it important that the
it's being led by glenn hutchins who's
the co-founder of private equity from
silver lake partners which is super
legit
so i think glenn is participating but
his son i think is the one who's
actually making a lot of the investment
decisions and then he has a partner
uh travis yeah from dcg uh so james is
uh glenn's son james is really
intelligent
i've talked to him before and uh i think
a lot of projects and companies are
going to want to work with
james and travis so this is pretty cool
to see kind of big backers
really smart managers right and they've
already got a couple investments on the
board so i think
i think it's uh one to watch next
jamal polypetia backed clover health
investment
said friday it received a notice of
investigation from the sec
and that it intends to cooperate clover
however pushed back against a critical
report from short selling specialist
hindenburg
research saying some claims in the
report were completely
untrue are the shirt sellers coming out
to play again
listen we've already talked about it if
you're a short seller
you're a loser we need you in the market
you should keep participating do your
thing
but this is the whole problem right this
is a perfect example
hindenburg research just wrote up this
big report
and then they released it my guess is
they have a short on
right meaning that they are short they
are betting that the company's stock is
going to go down
they then release a report regardless of
whether the
report is ends up being true or not
so allegations send the stock down 12
if they close their short now they would
book a massive profit
and it wouldn't matter whether it was
true or not wait i have a question can
you
i mean who are these research firms can
they just like release that
how who does their fact checking how do
they do their nobody
i don't understand how that's allowed
exactly my point
so i could be a short seller tomorrow i
could go i could short a stock and then
i could come out with a report and
because i have a big audience i can sue
you if it's not true right
it's i'm alleging it i'm gonna sue it
all everybody's gonna know
but it's just it's crazy like i could go
tomorrow i can push the stock down right
if i had a big enough audience
and then what i could do is close out my
short and book the profits and walk away
it's crazy this is this is nuts that we
let this happen in markets
because because if i
as the company was to put out reports
that were
untrue and the stock went up and then i
sold some of it
i would get in trouble yeah treat
everyone in the market equally
stop letting short sellers have an
advantage and by the way
just as an aside if you're a short
seller you're a loser like
why do you want to live your life as a
pessimist be optimistic have that friday
energy
that trillionaire energy pessimists you
just like a little worm laying on the
side of the road
ready to die waiting there just with
nothing to do in life
no purpose come on they have a purpose
it's fine go ahead okay
apple is working on an augmented and
virtual reality device
that's super ultra high-end and pricey
it's a vr headset that could hit stores
in 2022.
um it could
i'm not big on the vehicle it could cost
3 000
i'm really into the vr stuff so imagine
my great-grandmother at 91 years old
she puts on this vr headset she could be
in the
america do you want to know a company
that uh i almost started one time what
a lot i've never told a story before in
2015
i heavily considered starting a business
where uh using similar technology to
what google uses for google street view
you basically can have a big
backpack and you can go to certain
places and what it does is it takes a
360 degree capture at all times
and so let's say you go uh in the
himalayas or you go
uh scuba diving or you go walk somewhere
you have to be very active for
this idea that's why i wanted to
potentially do it you could go to like
disney world and walk around whatever
and then what you do is you bring it and
you get hospitals to buy it
so that kids who are sitting in the
hospital could basically put it on
and they could experience all this
different stuff the problem is that the
technology wasn't great too it was a
logistical nightmare
and then three was it wasn't clear that
hospital rules would actually buy this
stuff
and then within like nine months bitcoin
and i started mining and then like the
rest is history
but i like that idea better yeah but
that idea was
uh somebody's gonna do that one day
they're basically gonna create the
google maps
uh equivalent apple could be doing that
they could it's just
it's very difficult to pull off you need
a lot of resources uh and the technology
at the time wasn't really there because
one of the big problems is when you put
the vr headset on
uh and if there's too fast enough motion
uh it has like a little bit of a lag to
it
so it's getting better but it's it's not
quite ready for that level of uh
this one has over a dozen cameras like
yeah
i think it will get there eventually
we're talking literally we're five years
later
six years later right so it's like
already made a big improvement but 15
years from now
like i'm sure it'll look uh you know
near perfect
netflix dominated or sorry streaming
services dominated nominations for the
78th golden globe awards signaling a
power shift
in hollywood away from traditional movie
studios and cable and broadcast
television players
towards digital upstarts can we really
call netflix a digital upstart
so one of the key beneficiaries of that
change netflix towered over the
competition with a staggering
42 nominations across the film and tv
categories
including nods for the trial chicago
seven aaron's working really great
uh the queen's gambit also really good
and the crown i haven't watched it but
wow i mean look
classic vertical integration
start with really bad content then get a
little bit
then get a little bit better content get
people on lock them in your ecosystem
and then all of a sudden start to pull
away
uh other people's content and put your
own content when you vertically
integrate it makes you more profitable
and you have more control
super super smart netflix is an amazing
business if you watch
the stock price if you listen to the
earnings calls if you pay attention you
already know that
uh does not surprise me that they are
doing well amazon amazon studios all
still trying
shout out real quick if you don't know
who matthew ball is
uh he used to be the head of strategy i
think at amazon studios
he's fantastic absolutely fantastic i
highly suggest go search for him on
twitter
matthew ball you'll see him read every
single thing he puts out uh
if you write something time out put
everything to the side go read matthews
he's amazing he writes a lot about like
uh uh content streaming but also about
like the metaverse so the whole idea of
taking
like ip so let's say uh the avengers but
the avengers
isn't just a movie now now it may be in
vr it may be a video game
it may actually what happens if part of
the video game
is uh you play the video game to then
unlock something in a movie like you
start to connect all these different
pieces
in the metaverse all right next crazy
money oh it's asked lunch money time
hashtag
ask lm we got four minutes and we gonna
knock this out not cause the clock says
four because the
real clock says crazy money asks
thoughts on microstrategy what's your
thoughts i like michael saylor
i like him too a lot i've met him once
to be fair
but yeah most of y'all ain't done that
playing a medal uh
you did you actually had lunch with them
uh
the big thing about microstrategy is uh
the stocks that perform bitcoin is
pretty crazy
uh michael michael uh sailor has made
probably one of the most courageous
investment decisions that we've seen in
public markets in a long time he
put uh not from like a pure dollar
amount but just from a pure
percentage of assets under his control
so far has played out very very well
we're gonna see what happens here but uh
i think that michael saylor is going to
go down as one of the better ceos
in public markets when this is all said
and done so we'll see
but uh duh i'm a believer all right this
one comes from jared's salad bar
these are great usernames hey pimp and
pump i have a few interests that i'm
pretty passionate about in a perfect
world i would have the time and
resources to make all of them profitable
but realistically i can probably only
focus on one do due to working full-time
what could help me figure out which one
to prioritize i actually learned this
lesson
from him but um when you have a bunch of
things that you're
doing your attention and time is split
i would choose one thing do it full time
for like 30 days
if you enjoy it be like okay i'll
continue and dedicate more years of my
life to this
if you don't enjoy it move on to the
next thing but choose one so you can put
in a hundred percent of your time and
energy into it
instead of splitting it across a bunch i
would draw a venn diagram i would put
all the things on one side and then rank
them based on amount of effort
yeah venn diagram that overlaps that's
what a venn diagram is so on one side i
would put all of the things
ranked uh what takes the least amount of
effort what takes the most amount of
effort of what you're interested in on
the other side of the venn diagram what
i would do is i would put the things
based
on potential upside or impact right uh
and so is it measured by money is it
measured by reach by audience like
however you want to measure it just
what's the thing that could be the most
impactful or have the most upside
all the way to the one that has the
least and then what you basically want
to do is when you put them together
you're looking for the thing that fits
in the middle what's the thing that is
the highest up on
uh the list for least amount of effort
but has the highest upside and so when
you put that together that's the thing i
would go focus on first
okay just saying whatever lunch money
it's friday trillionaire energy if
you're a short seller stop being a
pessimist
if you got messed up here go to the
hairdresser if you want to hang out in
miami i'll see you on the streets
see you what's hope you guys enjoyed
this episode of lunch money as much as
we did
and don't forget lunch money is now
sponsored by block 5 so go check them
out there's a link in the description
that you can click
on i'm an investor a user and a huge fan
what you're a bigger fan of block five
than you are of me
block flies my second favorite thing in
the world behind paulina they've got
three products
they can give you a us dollar loan you
can earn up to eight point six percent
interest
on an interest bearing account or you
can buy and sell cryptocurrencies on
their crypto exchange
i personally use the interest bearing
account there's not very many places
where you'll find
up to 8.6 interest on a deposit in an
interest bearing account
go do your own research there's risk
associated but 8.6
is pretty compelling so click on the
link in the description say thanks to
the folks at blockfly
subscribe to our channel like the video
annoy pulling
in the comments and we'll see you guys
tomorrow and be kind to your friends